et pour gérer la situation éducative
dans le département une cellule de crise
est installée au sein des locaux de la
direction académique des yvelines
elle est ouverte depuis deux semaines et
fonctionne de 8h à 17h30 deux équipes se
relaient pour assurer une permanence
téléphonique tout au long de la journée
et répondre aux questions des directeurs
des établissements scolaires et des
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a rendu visite à la cellule vendredi
l'occasion pour charline à venelles de
préciser le dispositif pour assurer la
continuité pédagogique pendant la
période de fermeture
propos recueillis par grégory canal et
qu'elle passe par plusieurs éléments
elle passe par des des modalités de
d'enseignement à distance qui sont
prévues par le cned mais on a aussi
d'autres ressources qui passe par les
ent ou par des blogs d'enseignants et
puis cela passe par la possibilité
d'ouvrir des classes virtuelles une
classe virtuelle c'est un écran la
classe le professeur un tableau sur
lequel on peut écrire la possibilité de
lever la main de répondre et d'interagir
avec les élèves et la rectrice a précisé
que les établissements scolaires
restaient ouverts pour les enseignants
des réunions pédagogiques continuerons
de soutenir les professeurs pourront y
assurer les cours avec leur classe
virtuelle